bonjour à tous bienvenue à bruxelles au
coeur du parlement européen c'est parti
comme d'habitude pour 30 minutes
d'actualité européenne autour d'une
thématique quel modèle agricole pour
l'europe de demain dans cette émission
je vous emmène en allemagne les fermes
industrielles peuvent elles être une
solution à la crise agricole que
traverse l'europe
nous avons été à la rencontre d'un
agriculteur à la tête d'une exploitation
de grande taille mais d'abord
l'actualité le salon international de
l'agriculture a ouvert ses portes cette
semaine sur fond de crise agricole
une situation explosive le point avec
simon blain
ambiance tendue cette année au salon
international de l'agriculture à paris
lundi le premier ministre manuel valls
et suit un affront de la part des
agriculteurs le pas pourquoi tu vas là
samedi françois hollande est
sérieusement chahuté durant
l'inauguration du salon nous écoute plus
le stand du ministère a même été
saccagés quelques jours plus tôt des
dizaines d'éleveurs et de producteurs en
colère pousse le ministre de
l'agriculture stéphane le foll à sortir
de son domicile au mans pour venir
dialoguer avec eux tous demandent des
mesures fortes pour sortir de la crise
et ce n'est pas la baisse des charges
annoncées par le gouvernement qui
apaisera les tensions
le secteur français souffrent de graves
difficultés comme ses voisins européens
en cause la chute des cours et l'embargo
des produits européens par la russie
face à ce marasme
manuel valls interpelle le commissaire
européen à l'agriculture phil hogan pour
imposer à bruxelles des solutions
collectives
la commission doit faire maintenant des
annonces fortes prochain conseil des
ministres de l'agriculture décisif le 14
mars
alors peut-on ou pas sortir de la crise
agricole et y at il des remèdes en fait
à ces crises multiples qu on connaît
maintenant depuis plusieurs années c'est
je vais en parler avec mes invités josé
bové bonjour bonjour on ne vous présente
plus vous êtes député membre du groupe
des verts ici au parlement européen et
vous êtes ex leader de la confédération
paysanne et vous faites partie de la
commission agriculture au sein de ce
parlement
tout comme marc tarabella qui est à côté
de vous député socialiste et démocrate
belge merci et bienvenus j'ai en face de
vous yvan hayez
bonjour vous êtes secrétaire général de
la fwc la fédération wallonne de
l'agriculture
alors quand on voit ces images un peu
impressionnante un vraiment de tension
au salon de l'agriculture comme on en a
rarement connu les propositions du
gouvernement français en fait sont elles
suffisantes on a juste proposé une
baisse des charges et on voit que
globalement les négociations entre le
secteur de l'agroalimentaire et
notamment les producteurs laitiers a
shot
alors c'est quoi la solution josé bové
je pense que déjà ça fait plusieurs
années que les paysans tire la sonnette
d'alarmé
nous nous avons tiré la sonnette
d'alarmé ici pendant la réforme de la
pac
parce qu'on a vidé de l'ensemble de la
politique agricole tous les outils de
maîtrise de production et les derniers
qui ont été démantelées ce sont les
quotas laitiers n'entrent en scène à
partir de 2003 que la décision avait été
prise par madame fischer boel qui était
commissaire européenne à l'agriculture
et depuis tout a été mis en oeuvre et
tous les gouvernements qui se sont
succédé au niveau européen on cautionner
ça alors qu'on savait qu'à partir du
moment où on ouvrait les vannes de la
production est bien y allait avoir une
surproduction laitière en pleine marche
à suivre et marché ne suivrait pas donc
effondrement des prix et une fois de
plus ce sont les paysans qui paye les
pots cassés yvan hayez est-ce qu'il faut
rétablir les quotas laitiers quand on
voit que le prix de revient aujourd'hui
et ont tout autour de 33 centimes voire
36 centimes le litre qu'il est vendu 26
centimes sur le marché certainement
renoué en tout cas avec des outils de
régulation des marchés josé bové a parlé
d'un des aspects qui est les quotas et
là je souscris pleinement à ce qu'il a
dit est depuis 2003 on n'a cessé de dire
que cette
est une sottise sortir des quotas mais
aussi les outils de gestion notamment
les niveaux d'intervention et nous
serons avec la fédération wallonne de
l'agriculture présents ici à bruxelles
au prochain sommet des ministres
européens de l'agriculture est un bon
gars
venir demander qu'on renoue avec des
outils de régulation
l'important pour les agriculteurs avant
tout quelles que soient les aides qu'ils
puissent recevoir c'est d'avoir des prix
rémunérateurs
parce qu'effectivement la il fonctionne
à perte marc tarabella
est-ce qu'on peut compter sur phil hogan
qui est le commissaire européen à
l'agriculture pour revenir un petit peu
sur ses décisions et remettre des quotas
laitiers alors qu'on les a supprimées ya
plus presque quinze ans maintenant
ça m'étonnerait parce que le commissaire
hogan jusqu'à présent à d'abord nier
qu'il y avait une crise n'est pas
quelqu'un qui a pour leitmotiv de
vouloir réguler les marchés
c'est plutôt un ultralibéral qui veut
laisser faire le marché comme
l'essentiel est de la commission
européenne mais pas uniquement
l'ensemble des états membres la majorité
des états membres ne veulent plus régulé
quand on dit l'europe c'est la
commission c'est aussi le conseil s'est
aussi les gouvernements et dans ce
parlement nous sommes minoritaires avec
josé bové et quelques autres en tout cas
minoritaire on voudrait avoir des
mécanismes de régulation que ce soit les
quotas ou une politique de maintien des
prix ou d'être contracyclique les
américains le font
jean pierre a rappelé les aides qu'on
trace écrite c'est quoi ces corps que
comme les américains quand le marché
n'est pas porteur
eh bien ils ont défilé sécurité c'est à
dire un prix compensatoires pour leur
assurer un revenu ici on fait exactement
l'inversé
alors je retire attention sur le grand
danger qui nous guette le tti p le
traité transatlantique olive agricole se
serait catastrophique le signer et
d'ailleurs les américains ont déjà
sortir documents officiels qui montrent
que je gagnerais et que nous perdrions
et là ce serait encore une crise avec
beaucoup plus de problèmes pour toute
une série de productions notamment la
volaille le secteur du port de la viande
de boeuf est probablement le secteur
laitier également mais alors le problème
pour être clair c'est quoi c'est la
dérégulation ou c'est le poids de
l'agroalimentaire et des centrales
d'achat qui cherche à faire baisser les
prix on a tendance en fait t'as pas y
voir très clair dans les responsabilités
josé bové de qui on parle en fait dans
cette crise alors je crois qu'il ya d'un
côté le fait de ne pas maîtriser les
volumes okla souvent l'industrie de la
transformation est très intéressé parce
que quand les prix
baysse et bien effectivement leurs
matières premières et plus basse mais
eux au niveau des marges
il continue à maintenir leurs marges
parfois même les augmenter en dix ans la
part qui revient aux agriculteurs dans
la plus value de l'ensemble de la chaîne
alimentaire est passée de 30% à 20%
c'est le redire que récupère cette alors
qu'ils récupèrent très simple pour
moitié à peu près la transformation pour
l'autre moitié
la distribution est ce renvoi saad aux
ados japon en disant non c'est pas moi
c'est vous etc
il faut pas dû on a en france par
exemple deux grands acteurs
lactalis qui était une entreprise privée
mais familial avait aucun compte sur la
table impossible de savoir ce qui se
passe pareil dans la viande autres
acteurs privés bigard aucune
transparence donc aujourd'hui
effectivement ces entreprises disent
c'est la grande distribution
quand on l'a démontré nos les chiffres
ce que j'aime dans ces années on n'a
aucun chiffre
alors qu'effectivement il continue
d'augmenter alors mais il ya autre chose
à moi j'ai vu ce qui m'a quand même un
petit peu frappés que intermarché et
leclerc qui sont de grandes enseignes
françaises avaient mis en place en fait
d accord pour acheter du porc puisque
c'est aussi l'autre secteur qui souffre
de surproduction 20 et qui a du mal en
fait à vendre pas à perte et ces deux
groupes avaient mis en place donc d
accord pour acheter le port à prix
plancher est aujourd'hui à cause de cela
bruxelles les attaques et il risque une
amende avant il y avait ce qu'on n'est
pas là dans une forme d' absurdité aussi
de la part de la commission européenne
mais ce que ce qui est dénoncé l' essai
c'est scandaleux quelque part c'est
qu'il ya une déconnexion totale de la
société par rapport à une chose qui est
élémentaire c'est se nourrir une brique
de lait une côtelette de porc mais
maintenant des morceaux nobles de boeuf
sont vendus comme produits d'appel et il
ya une déconnexion totale entre le fait
noble de se nourrir
bon ben là on peut discuter et road y en
eut pas de viande et les quantités par
semaine ça c'est un débat diététique
mais le fait de vendre et se servir d'un
produit laitier qui est quand même un
produit noble qui est le premier
on est mammifères de le brader et de le
vendre à au prix le plus bas pour
attirer le consommateur est quelque
chose à proprement sur l'alimentation à
baisser les charges globales en fait des
ménages
il ya une déconnexion qui se fait entre
l'acte de consommation
l'achat de la consommation tels qu on
devrait peut-être rappeler à nos
concitoyens parce que derrière ça il ya
des hommes et les femmes qui travaillent
acteurs finalement c'est à dire changer
ses habitudes alimentaires et comprendre
que ces aliments là en fait on a un coût
qui n'est pas celui qu'on a fait alors
comment on fait marc tarabella pour
faire plier la masia entre guillemets
agroalimentaire oui moi je rappellerai
pas ça la mafia d'abord la production
l'agroalimentaire ça transforme 80 % la
production agricole
ce qu'il faut c'est évidemment mettre de
l'ordre moi j'aurais souhaité à l'époque
que le pouvoir public soit le gendarme
du marché et qu'on attribue une force
évidemment négociations aux producteurs
mais avec la tutelle de l'autorité
publique
mais ça on n'en veut pas ici à bruxelles
l'europe n'aurait plus on nous parle de
bureaucratie il s'agit pas de
bureaucratie il s'agit dans l'est de la
france à ceux qui n'en n'ont pas au
maillon le plus faible comme vient de
l'appeler yvan hayez le faire en sorte
que tous les acteurs sont autour de la
table
l'agroalimentaire la distribution mais
aussi les producteurs est de faire en
sorte qu'on puisse qui ne puisse pas
vendre à perte
aujourd'hui ils ont clairement à perte
le prix moyen du lait est en-deça
largement du coût de production ça n'est
pas normal et ce depuis maintenant
plusieurs mois d'affilée donc ce n'est
même plus que le marché est erratique et
est hyper volatil
il reste anormalement bas et donc non
rémunérateurs c'est vrai pour le
laissera ses vrais beaux supprimer l' on
voit que l'on sort une nouvelle fois
d'une négociation avec tous les acteurs
et que ça a chopé de nouveau donc
qu'est-ce qu'il va falloir faire pour
que enfin des solutions sorte de tout ça
écoutez moi je pense y a ça a été dit à
la fois par yvan hayez et marc tarabella
way aujourd'hui on a un vrai problème
sur les prix moi j'ai été paysan pendant
plus de trente ans quand je livrais une
laiterie mon lait de brebis
c'est eux qui me fixait le prix et qui
me faisait la facture ce qui était quand
même assez incroyable
on fonctionne à l'envers c'est à dire
qu'on fonctionne à l'envers on est le
seul métier celui de paysans
on ne fixe pas le prix de vente de son
produit c'est celui qui vous l'achète il
fixe ça veut dire qu'il ya un moment les
choses ne vont pas quand ce prix ne
couvrent pas vos charges evouna le
dégager pas de revenu il ya un moment ça
ne peut plus fonctionner donc pour moi
je crois que c'est une chose essentielle
et c'est ce que j'ai demandé au ministre
agriculture français jeudi il fallait
fait imposer un prix plancher
il couvre les charges c'est anormal
aujourd'hui qu'en europe on n'est pas
cette situation jeu on l'a votée ici au
parlement européen j'avais fait un
rapport en 2010 dans lequel je demandais
un prix plancher qui couvre les coûts de
production moyens
ça a été voté à une très large majorité
du parlement européen c'est ainsi
l'accord reçu alors yahia depuis de
nombreuses années en fait on nous vend
un modèle productiviste et on a été
justement voir un petit peu comment ça
se passait en allemagne avec ces fermes
de grande taille qui ont donc pignon sur
mur sur rue
on les a vus en ex rda mais elles
commencent à fleurir sur tout le
territoire allemand certaines des fois
cette exploitation par dans compte des
milliers de bovins et des dizaines de
milliers de porcs alors est-ce une
alternative à la crise on a voulu aller
voir et c'est samia déchiré violette
bonnes bases qui se sont rendus à la
ferme de kannberg reportage
c'est un rituel bien huilé trois fois
par jour pendant 5 heures ce carrousel
voit défiler
mille deux cents vaches dans la
coopérative laitière de came berg en
allemagne de l'est la traite est
entièrement automatisé seuls trois
employés encadrent le bétail surveillé
par huit caméras dizaine d'assaillants
grâce à vous le voyez là il y à une
caméra on voit les vaches dans la cour
de la haye la rive dans le carrousel là
ça nous montre à quel emplacement elles
sont prêtes
combien de l'est elle donne tout et
identifier les informations sont
récoltés pour savoir à la fin quelle
quantité de lait a été produite dans le
carrousel
en allemagne de l'est ce gigantisme n'a
rien d'exceptionnel du temps de la rda
toutes les fermes ont été collectiviser
celle de ken berg a compté jusqu'à deux
mille vaches
après la chute du mur elle a rouvert
sous forme de coopératives privées
gérées par plusieurs familles vestiges
de l'époque communiste ces bâtiments
vétustes sont aujourd'hui inutilisées en
2014 la coopérative a été entièrement
rénové pour résister à une concurrence
de plus en plus rude
ramlakan nous nous sommes dit après
avoir produit pendant 40 ans dans les
anciens bâtiments que nous avions besoin
de changer nos conditions de travail
nous voulions le faire au bon moment ne
pas rater le train en marche mais nous
adapter aux conditions que nous impose
le marché mondial
coût de l'opération 10 millions d'euros
les vaches produisent désormais jusqu'à
40 litres de lait par jour soit 10 de
plus qu'avant la présence humaine est
réduite au minimum dix neuf personnes en
tout pour les 1200 vaches même le
ramassage du lisier est automatisée est
envoyé directement dans ces méthaniseur
comme les éoliennes
ils produisent de l'énergie revendus aux
compagnies d'électricité
sur un an la revente de l'énergie nous
permet de financer les salaires pendant
trois mois un mois avec le méthaniseur
un mois avec le photovoltaïque est un
mois avec le parc éolien une source de
revenus indispensables car ces fermes
industrielles érigés en modèles ne sont
en fait pas rentable un litre de lait
coûte 33 centimes à produire pour un
prix d'achat de 26 centimes
33 centimes ce serait le prix plancher
là on se dirait que notre travail est
respecté mais faire plus d'économies
dans les coûts de production ce n'est
plus possible
nous ne voyons pas ce que nous pourrions
faire de plus vu les millions d'euros
empruntés pour leur modernisation
les fermes industrielles sont
vulnérables face à la chute des cours du
lait l'industrialisation ne protègerait
donc pas les exploitants le modèle n'est
pas rentable et il est de plus en plus
contesté en janvier dernier des milliers
de personnes défilent tu à berlin contre
l'élevage de masse elle dénonce entre
autres la pollution générée par les
fermes industrielles
car pour nourrir leurs bêtes ces
exploitations cultive des centaines
d'hectares de céréales ou d'herbe
arrosés de pesticides beaucoup d'oeufs
bio aérosols et de substances
proviennent des fermes industrielles
ils sont très concentrés et contaminent
directement l'environnement
on a remarqué que le paysage s'était
déjà a complètement modifié avec les
apports en azote des plantes
complètement nouvelles se sont
implantées
en allemagne de l'est la colère monte
dans le brandebourg un collectif
d'associations a lancé une pétition dans
l'espoir d'organiser un référendum
régional contre l'élevage de masse 80
mille signatures étaient nécessaires
ils en ont récolté plus de 100 milles
ils demandent notamment la fin des
subventions aux fermes industrielles car
les aides de la pac sont attribués en
fonction du nombre d'hectares ha celui
qui a beaucoup d'hectares reçoit
beaucoup d'argent celui qui a moins
d'hectares reçoit peu d'argent les
élevages biologiques qui se lancent
aujourd'hui au moins deux terrains donc
moins d'argent
donc nous nous disons pas de subventions
liées à la surface
le collectif réclame des subventions
conditionné au respect de
l'environnement et du bien-être animal
le parlement local se prononcera en mars
si les députés votent contre
ce sont les citoyens du brandebourg qui
seront appelés aux urnes
difficile de prévoir l'issue du
référendum mais une chose est sûre ce
modèle subventionné à grands frais
montre aujourd'hui ses limites
yvan hayez alors même ces fermes
industrielles qu'on pensait être une
alternative n'en sont pas une on voit
que le prix de revient là aussi faire le
prix plancher n'est pas atteint est-ce
qu'on n'est pas la fin d'un cycle est ce
qu'on n'est pas à la fin d'un monde et
d'un modèle agricole
effectivement depuis toujours parce que
faut rappeler que les agriculteurs sont
avant tout des entrepreneurs les progrès
sur 50 ans de pâques les progrès de la
science de l'accompagnement à grenoble
elle combine le ils ont naturellement
toujours cherché à se développer à
s'agrandir
heureusement ce qui nous concerne en
wallonie je pense ou à dire qu'on garde
une agriculture qui est relativement au
même très étroitement lié au sol
nous avons peu de développement de
spéculation hors sol
il ya un peu de ports un peu de volaille
mais c'est relativement restreint et
effectivement cette année six roues ces
deux trois dernières années annonçant la
sortie des quotas certains se sont dit
qu'on va aller chercher l'économie
d'échelle pour rester pour tenter de
rester tous ces grandes fermes dans un
environnement mondial marc tarabella est
ce que le modèle justement aujourd'hui
on voit c'est une demande en fête
citoyenne de savoir d'où viennent nos
d'où vient notre alimentation d'être en
capacité de suivre un petit peu son
cheminement et surtout de consommer un
peu responsable est ce que justement là
je vais vous reposer la question mais
est-ce que c'est pas la fin d'un cycle
et est-ce qu'on n'est pas en train
d'inventer autre chose
ceci le contre-exemple de son confrère
votre reportage a bien fait parce qu'ils
insistent sur le fait que
l'investissement hyper industriel ceci
n'est plus le fer au maintien d'une
industrie qui se sert du vivant pour
produire et de et du bétail en
particulier des vaches en l'occurrence
ça ne peut rien à voir et d'agriculture
familiale à taille humaine est liée au
sol avec le traitement des sols et celui
ici ce qui se passe c'est que la ferme
et votre reportage de montres lé pas
plus rentable que celui elle est même
moins rentables et plus vulnérable que
la crise heureusement qu'elle
méthaniseur finalement à 7 30 40 50
vaches ou 100 vaches et qui utilise
notamment ses herbes et qui est lié au
sol lui ce revers moins vulnérable parce
qu'il va avoir moins d'intrants ici on
parle de céréales à des pesticides qui
sont à côté de la ferme c'est aussi du
soja qui vient d'outre-atlantique et les
vaches ne voit plus la prairie il ya
évidemment un sérieux problème
et puis c'est aussi les mêmes ici qui
nous parle du bien-être animal je
constate que c'est dans le nord de
l'europe de ce genre de d'industrie a
plus le vent en poupe le danemark
notamment la suède l'allemagne est
malheureusement certains croient que ce
soit agriculture là est celle qui s'est
modernisée or je le répète c'est parfois
les typiquement on voit qu'en france
c'est un peu ce que prône la fnsea
fédération nationale soit le plus gros
syndicat qui représente la plupart des
agriculteurs
l'idée c'est de grossir pour pouvoir à
vos atteindre une taille critique et
donc peser sur le marché
et est ce que c'est aujourd'hui josé
bové une stratégie suicidaire quand on
voit et je prends ce mot sciemment quand
on voit qu'on compte aujourd'hui 600
suicides d'agriculteurs parents qui
arrive justement qui n'arrivent plus à
prendre en charge leur exploitation qui
n'arrivent plus à rembourser leurs
dettes
grossir ça veut dire mourir à terme en
tout cas les études aujourd'hui montre
très clairement que ce sont les
exploitations modernisée dans ces
dernières années qui sont les plus
fragiles ceux qui ont tenté les coûts
d'avoir des productions d'un million de
litres de lait aujourd'hui c'est eux qui
ont les coûts de production les plus
élevés au delà de 40 centimes du litre
ce qui veut dire très clairement essais
des études qui ont été faites maintenant
au dessus d'un certain niveau de
production
il n'y a aucun gain de productivité au
contraire ça coûte de plus en plus cher
et donc l'agriculture ne peut pas être
traité comme une usine qui fait des
voitures ou des frigos industries comme
les autres on ne peut pas robotisée
l'agriculture en croyant qu'on va faire
des économies d'échelle parce que à la
fois il ya la question du bien-être
animal
il ya la question de l'environnement
parce que ces animaux restent enfermés
24 heures sur 24 et pia la question
sociale c'est à dire que c'est toute la
désertification des campagnes qui est en
train de se faire si on a ce modèle en
france demain sur 100 départements on en
a besoin de 15 pour produire c'est à
dire que
toute la multifonctionnalité
l'agriculture disparaît et quand je vois
cette sphère moi j'ai qu'une seule chose
à dire c'est que la viande et le lait
qui sont produits dans cette firme en
fait sont les sous-produits de la merde
qui sert à faire tourner les dix génique
c'est à dire que les connaît mais elle
se connecte dont les prix peuvent
baisser
et souvent c'est un véritable scandale
et sociales agroalimentaire yvan hayez
la fin d'un cycle je vais essayer de
répondre même si j'ai pas la réponse
c'est que je voulais simplement dire
c'est que un homme gère un troupeau 60
65 matchs ça c'est un an
voilà le problème c'est que en gérant
correctement ses 65 vaches et gagne sa
vie il puisse élever disons deux enfants
et avoir une carrière qui est correct
alors de deux choses l'une
l'europe en fait l'agriculture couteaux
européens entre 100 et 120 euros par
citoyen européen par an soit on continue
et on soutient le revenu des
agriculteurs
ce qui est en train de disparaître d'une
certaine manière soit
et moi je travaille au niveau de la
filière la concertation chaîne je ne
suis pas là pour faire le le prix des
autres maillons et la marge des autres
maillons je dis simplement que produire
à l'idée de laisser autant il faut
partir de ça chacun a sa marche et ils
filent et le consommateur doit être
conscient que c'est normal de payer un
tel prix pour le violer alors on voit
que depuis cette crise de plus en plus
d'agriculteurs souhaite passer en bio
parce qu'on voit bien que pour le coup
là le bio fonctionne et ça se vend
correctement à des prix qui sont à la
hauteur de l'investissement de
l'agriculteur finalement il faut quoi
monter en qualité pour pouvoir prétendre
à vivre correctement
josé bové moi je crois que d'abord ce
sont les consommateurs qui choisissent
ça qui est intéressant c'est que on
parlait tout à l'heure des
consom'acteurs cee aujourd'hui qui
oriente ils veulent des petites fermes
petite ou moyenne
ils veulent l agriculture de plus en
plus saines avec le bien-être animal
et ils veulent des produits de la gamme
sans pesticides 10 % du lait aujourd'hui
vendus en france du lait en bouteille
c'est du lait issus de l'agriculture
biologique c'est quand même un signe
très important
donc c'est pour ça qu'on se bat ici au
niveau du parlement pour essayer de
d'améliorer les règles sur l'agriculture
biologique pour faire en sorte qu'on
puisse augmenter le nombre d'années
alors justement à ce propos josé bové la
transition est parfaite j'ai ouï dire qu
il y a un rapport avec cela il ya une
négociation en ce moment sur la
labellisation bio et que le rapporteur
qui est membre du groupe des verts dans
lequel vous êtes vous-même serait prêt à
lâcher face à la commission et au
conseil pour que l'on puisse avoir même
des pesticides dans les produits qui
seraient labellisés bio c'est vrai ou
pas est-ce que les verts vont tuer le
bio alors ce qui est intéressant c'est
définitivement c'est un vert allemand
martin gosling qui pourra porter et donc
il est aujourd'hui donc ce qu'on appelle
le trilogue au niveau européen c'est la
négociait sa négociation avec la
commission de monsieur hogan s'est pas
celles de dacia ciolos qu'on avait avant
hétéro et le conseil sous présidence
néerlandaise et là c'est la castagne
c'est la castagne parce qu'effectivement
tout les libéraux aujourd'hui refusent
par exemple qu'on puisse être dans une
logique qui irait on commence avec sa
ferme sur une production
et bien cette production demain
l'ensemble de l'exploitation devrait
être en bio à l'espace de sept ans dix
ans pour aller dans une dynamique
d'augmentation
impossible de faire passer ça pour
l'instant impossible aussi aujourd'hui
sont en train de nous dire ben écoutez
il ya peut-être des résidus de
pesticides mais c'est à griffin allemand
en gros s'il ya des résidus de
pesticides
ça va être déplacée mais qui va payer
et c'est là où il faut avec le principe
pollueur payeur c'est dire que les
fabricants de pesticides doivent payer
parce que la question biologique lui
quand il fut plante tout son processus
est contrôlé il a un cahier des charges
mais au final elle son produit est
pénalisé ouais eh bien personne lundi
midi c'est un scandale
marc tarabella c'est un scandale mais il
faut l'enjeu il est il est clair c'est
dommage que josé bové n'a pas été
rapporteur il aurait été plus strict que
son collègue allemand il peut pas le
dire lui moi je le dis son collègue
allemand est moins efficace que lui mais
lui peut pas le dire bonjour
ouvertement je dis simplement qu'il faut
préserver le bio c'était une niche à une
époque aujourd'hui ça devient un
business
ces 22 milliards d'euros à l'échelle
européenne est ce qu'il faut éviter
c'est de le dénaturer
on fait rentrer des gens qui ne veulent
pas faire du vrai bio et qui trompent
les consommateurs
et ça c'est de là qu'elle est en jeu
aujourd'hui la décertification c'est
important et effectivement il ya aussi
le code civil le même en france qu'en
belgique la responsabilité civile celui
qui pollue le champ son voisin doit
payer
il faut pas de fonds d'indemnisation
parce que le problème c'est que ça
déresponsabilise il faut que celui qui
pollue et qui n'a pas pris des
précautions pour préserver le champ de
son voisin bio paye un moment donné est
clairement la désertification c'est
important la mixité
moi je suis pas pour la mixité la mixité
dans une exploitation bio et comment une
opposition vers le bio et on doit y
croire et clairement avoir un vrai bio
que les consommateurs qui se paye 30 à
50% de plus air pas être trompée et donc
il doit avoir pour moi une grande grande
attention à ce que le label ne soit pas
dénaturé les gens ont besoin d'avoir
cette confiance en plus aller croissante
aujourd'hui parce la consommation bio
est en demande à l'arrêt attention aussi
aux ses importations exiger la même
qualité des importations parce
qu'aujourd'hui et savamment choisis sur
le label soit pas les courts du passé
rapidement il voyait le bio donc c'est
évidement il est clair que le bio est en
pleine émergence il faut l'accompagner
il ne faut pas non plus les tout fait en
allant trop vite
moi ce que je veux dire et j'ai parfois
ça me fait mal parfois d'entendre ces
discussions comme s'il y avait des bons
et les mauvais non l'agriculture est en
mutation permanente
il faut l'encadrer il faut l'accompagner
et josé bové avait raison
disons il ya une attente de la société
mais les attentes sont multiples et le
consommateur n'a pas nécessairement le
même comportement en semaine quand il
est pressé ou le week-end quand il a un
peu le temps et donc je ne voudrais pas
qu'on oppose les agricultures qu'on la
fasse évoluer et est rappelé que c'est
vrai aussi et les sondages organisés par
la commission le monde entre les
attentes sociétales des concitoyens et
le comportement de ces mêmes concitoyens
en termes de conservation iai est à
revoir et 7 bat en face non plus donc
voilà il y a
tout blanc ni tout écouter ce sera le
mot de la fin merci messieurs nous avoir
éclairé sur ces questions complexes et
j'espère que tout ceci vous aura permis
d'y voir un peu plus clair
vous retrouverez la semaine prochaine
ahmed tazir mais pour l'instant pour
nous c'est fini
ciao
vos rangs